>>> WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS VOL VOLCANO ALL WEEK.
IT IS NOW JUST THREE MILES AWAY
FROM LITERALLY HITTING THE
HIGHWAY.
AUTHORITIES SAY IT COULD REACH
THE INTERSTATE IN A WEEK.
DAVID, WHAT IS IT ACTUALLY LIKE
TO BE THERE?
YOU WERE DRIVING INTO THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT AND BOOM.
>> WE WERE.
WE WERE MID-CONVERSATION AND
THERE'S FEW THINGS THAT CAN
H
SILENCE A GROUP OF JOURNALISTS
ON CAFFEINE IS YOU TURN ON THE
HIGHWAY AND IT'S THE GLOW.
HERE IT IS, 2, 3 IN THE MORNING
AND YOU CAN SEE THE REALLY
MAJESTY OF THIS.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT FIZZIER THREE.
THIS IS NOT EVEN THE SUMMIT,
GUYS.
THAT IS MILES AWAY.
STILL IT'S STUNNING.
IT'S THE MOST ACTIVE AND STABLE
FLOW AT THIS HOUR.
LOCALS HAVE BEEN PASSING BY
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, FAMILIES
TAKING OVER, TAKING PHOTOS AND
SOME OF THEM JUST STANDING IN
SILENCE, LETTING THE MAJESTY OF
THIS SEEP IN.
OFFICIALS ARE STILL PRETTY
VIGILANT HERE.
A FEW HOURS AGO THEY UPDATED THE
LAVA FLOW BUT IT'S STILL HEADED
TOWARDS THAT MAIN HIGHWAY THAT
YOU MENTIONED, THAT'S SADDLE
ROAD.
CUTTING THAT OFF WOULD CREATE A
LOGISTICAL NIGHTMARE FOR
RESIDENTS.
THEY'RE HOPING IT DOESN'T GET TO
THAT BUT IT COULD.
WHAT'S BILL OWING OUT OF THE TOP
IS NOT SMOKE BUT THAT'S ACTIVE
GAS.
THAT COULD CAUSE SERIOUS HEALTH
PROBLEMS FOR RESIDENTS.
SORRY TO BLOCK YOUR VIEW.
YOU'VE GOT THIS BALANCE BETWEEN
THE CONCERN, THE URGENCY OF THIS
VERY REAL BUT ALSO THE
APPRECIATION AND RESPECT.
AND THAT COMES FROM THE
OFFICIALS.
A FEW HOURS AGO AS THEY WERE
TALKING AT THE LATEST PRESS
CONFERENCE, THEY SAY YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND IT'S THE REASON THAT
HALF IF NOT MORE OF THIS BIG
ISLAND EXISTS, THE LAND THAT
PEOPLE LIVE ON IS BECAUSE OF
ERUPTIONS LIKE THIS.
SO THERE IS THIS DEEP
APPRECIATION.
STILL THEY'RE HOPING PEO